so berserking um yeah the nightbot
nightbot knows cuts my time in half but
gives me a better better tournament
score
builds berserk again
also leads to faster games so i'll
probably get one more game after this
okay that was that's not intentional but
at least i didn't blunder a piece
uh play g5 maybe
it takes 95
oh no my bishop
ah
i'm gonna be down a piece
it's castle queen side
starting made in one
oh he's got a fight you never know
miracles are
oh miracles might not exist in this game
okay this is something
man this is really something common
i'm not losing
let's take that so i won back the piece
let's try and walk up on the the queen
side
a little bit stuck here
okay
okay it's a prime position for the
rosentrap
let's go let's go let's go
black made four queens black tried to
humiliate
me
i was just waiting for the sack i wasn't
expecting blacks to make four queens and
then sack
that's so great i i tried to
give myself like just enough time so
this this wasn't um or this wasn't a
pre-move
let's go how to survive
when opponent makes four queens
one of these queens okay
one more game
what was i saying about miracles and
them sometimes not happening
but they sometimes do happen